foreign
is with us in Center Rose California hi
Julianne how are you
well hello Dave and Ken thanks so much
for taking my call your your show is a
real blessing thank you how can we help
so so I am 63 years old and pardon me
I've got I make about 64 000 a year
um I've got eighteen thousand dollars in
credit card debt I'm looking to retire
at 68.
um Ken I've listened to you talk about
that have a passion for what you do and
well I don't think I'm in that group but
I do work in a government position and I
will be getting a pension so that is why
I'm there I'm looking as I said I'm
looking to retire at 68.
um and Mike my question is I just and I
have about a hundred thousand dollars in
Combined 401k and the sarsap and when I
retire my the two pensions I'll get plus
my social security from a higher paying
job before will equals pretty much what
I'm making now but you qualify for those
pensions now don't you
uh no I don't the one pension was with a
law firm and I have to wait till I'm 65
to to get that okay what about the other
the other one I don't quite have five
years in yet so no I can't get that
either if I stop at five uh in within
the next six months or so but that will
be a lot less than if I wait another
five years which is why I was gonna
retire at 68 then that'll make me
eligible for Social Security as well I
my social security is at 66 to 10 months
but I figure 68 will put 10 years in at
my government job and then I would use
the money as I need
um in the hundred thousand in the
combined 401k and starstep I live in
affordable housing so I have no property
or anything what's your question
my question is is um
how do I leverage getting the most out
of my situation
be more specific what do you mean what
are you trying to Leverage
um I'm trying to
um have a better standard of a living
retire I because before I retire I to
pay off the 18 000 in credit card I
don't know how I'm going to do that and
then I also I have a beater van from
when my mom pays of course I don't have
that anymore and so I was looking to get
one more car for like my forever car and
I don't know how I'm going to make all
that happen sure you do get three five
years I'm sure you do well that's why
you called Dave's going to help you but
I'm going to give you the formula though
so you can get your head right number
one you need to you need to pay off your
debt and you might need to supplement
your income right now to make that
happen faster and then you're going to
be fine you got to pay off this debt
and I I work I was thinking about that
thank you and I work full time
um and I don't know how I I I've
listened to the side over time you work
40 hours overtime is your answer they
are they full-time is 80.
uh no we're 40 hours a week I don't know
that's eight hours five days a week and
they don't pay overtime they will not
authorize it I know so go get a job
working doing something else in addition
to this
work more
okay that's my only option
oh you have another option continue to
stay broke
no it's it's depressing it really is and
I don't want to be depressed yeah so I
don't I don't know how I would work in
addition because I work eight to five
five days a week and like I said I'm 63
I'm not 23 but so am I so
you're not an invalid
I work all the time I mean I'm 63. I you
know 16 hour days if I need to I'm
entirely possible I don't like doing it
either but I mean there's sometimes I
have to get crap done and so you got 18
000 worth of debt in a junkie van you
got to fix these things and you're gonna
need more money you're going to tighten
the budget that you've got
and you're gonna have to increase your
income
and uh
you need financial peace we've got the
process for you walk it through you're
discouraged you need to get determined
this is not a an unsolvable situation we
have the steps yeah hang on we'll give
you a copy of the book Total Money
Makeover and show you exactly what to do
but you're gonna have to increase your
income and you're gonna have to out
decrease your outgo so stuff you're
spending money on while you're sitting
around other than your 40 hours of work
uh you're not gonna be able to spend
money on that anymore because you're not
gonna be sitting around anymore there
you go